i want to know how do you go from uh
normal human being functioning in
society to reviewing the [ __ ] of the
round table on youtube
what's the origin story of that how do
you how do you get into that yes
voice acting online because we're in
like the same community but i you know
how did it like go from how did you get
into voice acting and then go into
that kind of side of youtube are you
asking how everything the beginning of
my life
yeah introduce you to our guests yeah
yeah all right
i guess like so i started out on youtube
when youtube just began i was about 12
13.
and i was a big anime nerd i was that
girl you know just like call me yumiko
kawagawa
and i was like what's the best way to be
the most closest to an anime girl that
you can but
and i was just like maybe being your
voice so i tried
doing voice acting and then i grew up
and i stopped doing fandoms and a bridge
series
because you were pretty big in the like
bridging scene back in the day weren't
you yeah i remember because
back when bridging was like at its prime
you had like team four star and then you
had
a lot of other people were trying to
emulate what team four star were doing
yeah and
we got to the point where people started
realizing hey if we use female voice
actresses
we could make our bridge series look
legit because most of bridge series were
just like dudes yeah oh
dude
it would just be like the dudes uh
playing the girl characters doing their
like best falsetto or whatever it's
called
um so if you had a female voice actor
that meant you're originally was like
legit but they have a budget the problem
is that there weren't many female voice
actresses
in the community so i remember like how
i discovered sydney was she was like one
of the five female voice actors
actresses who was just like in
everything right so that's that's how i
discovered you
like how was it back in the day for you
being like voicing in
so many different abridged series and so
many different paragraphs you were like
first generation like online voice actor
yeah i was i started when i was like 14.
i i mean back then obviously i was kind
of like around when the boom of it kind
of began obviously when people were like
[ __ ] girls want a voice in our [ __ ]
terrible
parody
and so i like i get a lot of offers
every day because there's not many girls
who have like microphones yeah
oh i guess my me and my blue yeti
project if we have to
so it was like you know i felt like hot
[ __ ]
i mean yeah like female voice actors
were a wanted commodity yeah you were
like
whoa so um i it was pretty fun you know
i felt like
a celebrity like what you don't know who
i am i'm in
i forgot my i forgot my fame sunglasses
oh god they know i was in that fourth
pokemon bridge oh jesus
so so i gotta ask like were there a lot
of projects that you were in that um
you may be not so proud of now like
looking back at i think you can
say without without
there are a probably i'd say about like
a good like seventy percent
seventy percent or like a voice actor
yeah
maybe even close to 90 because very
rarely and this is gonna sound terrible
but like
when i was in the parities i only
laughed i'd say very like one or two
three
none of them were funny i'm sorry oh my
god
every every every abridger whose voice
with sydney is just like maybe i'm the
ten percent
i was like i'm the ten percent i could
be the ten percent funny right will you
ever like cast another cause you okay
if you were one of the five female did
you ever get like cast in a project and
then you're like cool cool this is good
and then you hear the other voice actors
and you're like how do i get out of this
how do i how do i how do i back the [ __ ]
up of course because like back then it's
just like they're like oh you're a girl
even though you're using your
like laptop mic i've never acted before
but
it's just like of course um but you know
sometimes like i was like i'm
unfortunately one of those people that's
like once i kind of offer something it's
really hard for me to say like
i'm just not gonna do it it's like it's
really hard to say no
so most of the time i just i'm like i'm
gonna do the lines but i'm not gonna do
it without enthusiasm like
yeah i i feel like that's just the best
way to practice from what i've heard
i'd say with a lot of things you just
got to do it even if you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
you're going to suck for the longest
time and then you eventually learn how
to do it just
audition just never stop auditioning and
then you'll get better that was
definitely how it was back then it's
like
even if it was all [ __ ] it's practice
yeah yeah yeah
but yeah so how did you try like what so
when did you ever stop voice acting or
is it something you just kind of lost
interest in
like i mean that kind of plays into how
we met isn't it like because we met
from his abridged series ava bridge in
case you guys
couldn't guess oh my god here we go
but um once i we started dating i
actually moved
like after we started like i moved to
england and i started going to school in
england
and i think from that point i stopped
voice acting for a good few years um
but then i came back because i was just
like you know you you said like you
think i should try and do youtube and
i'm like i don't know voice acting's not
in the same community and you're like
maybe don't do voice acting
[Music]
and then i started doing manga videos
because i really like manga
right and um i started noticing like
people tended to prefer what i talked
about some of the looter titles like it
started off with like jk haru as a sex
worker
and to like you know naval sex
of course no i i think the big
transition was
when you did your video on euphoria yeah
right i feel like
god has all the answers to these
questions he's like no sydney that's not
harry
i was there
he was though he was like god's like
human fact-checker he was the one who
like actually i i definitely wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for garn he like
helped pave the way kind of told me what
he's like hey this like might be a good
thing and i'm like i don't know
and anytime i needed advice he was there
yeah because i remember when i saw some
of your thumbnails i'm like that's not
that's not the level of clickbait from
someone who's been taking this for
four months and i was like did you make
the thumbnails like yeah yeah i did
like i knew